- [Voiceover] Smell perception
in mammals involves the
interactions of airborne odorant molecules
from the environment
with receptor proteins
on the olfactory neurons
in the nasal cavity.
The binding of odorant molecules
to the receptor proteins
triggers action potentials
in the olfactory
neurons and results in
transmission of information to the brain.
Mammalian genomes typically
have approximately
one thousand functional
odorant-receptor genes,
each encoding a unique odorant receptor.
Alright, part a,
describe how the signal
is transmitted across
the synapse from an activated olfractory
sensory neuron to the interneuron
that transmits the
information to the brain.
Alright, so let's draw this out.
So, this is part a, so
let's, let me draw the
activated olfactory sensory neuron,
so, it might, so those
are its dendrites, there,
so, I'm not gonna draw a perfect,
so those are its dendrites
right over there,
and this is its axon,
it's axon,
and then this is the axon terminals.
The axon terminals, just like that.
And I could draw other details if I want,
I don't think you'd have to
draw all of these details
on the actual test.
But, just to get a sense of things,
we could also draw the
well, we could do it in a different color,
we could also draw
the nucleus right over there.
So this is the activated
olfactory sensory neuron,
so activated
olfactory, olfactory sensory neuron.
sensory neuron.
And let me draw, let me
draw the interneuron.
So, the interneuron,
so I'll draw one of its
dendrites right over there.
So this is the interneuron,
drawing its dendrites,
and then its axon.
I'll draw it a little
bit better than that,
its axon just like that
and it goes to the brain.
And if we zoom in on the synapse,
where we have to transmit
the signal between the two,
so if we zoom in,
if we zoom in,
right over there,
we would see the axon terminal of the
sensory neuron.
So, maybe it looks something like that.
And then the, the, the interneuron
right over that.
Just like this.
And this is the synapse.
So, this is the zoomed in of the synapse.
And the activated
olfactory sensory neuron,
you have this activation potential
that is going to go down the axon,
and then when it gets to
when it gets to the axon
terminal right over here,
it will trigger the release
of neurotransmitters.
So, these neurotransmitters are typically
hanging out in, in these, these vessels
right over here, but then when
the action potential comes,
they will get released
into the synaptic cleft.
And then, the interneuron
is going to have,
is going to have proteins
that sense, that sense
those neurotransmitters,
and that activates that neuron.
So, once again this is the interneuron,
interneuron, and we could
say that interneuron,
interneuron
gets activated, actually
it could be inhibited
as well, but activated
by, by neurotransmitters
neurotransmitters
released into synapse,
released into synapse
by the sensory neuron,
by sensory neuron due to action potential,
due to action,
action potential.
And this is probably enough, but I
went through a few more
pains to draw it out
a little bit, and you
could draw other details.
You could draw the myelin
sheath and all of that,
you could draw the nuclei
of the different cells,
but the basic idea is
that the signal goes from
one neuron to another
with the release of these,
these chemicals, these neurotransmitters,
which are actually fairly,
fairly small molecules,
but then they trigger the next neuron,
and then after that
signal goes they get all
they get metabolized by enzymes and things
and there might be a few
that just always stick around
but for the most part they signal
from one neuron to another.
And they could activate the next neuron,
or they actually could inhibit it as well,
but in this case, they
would probably activate.
Alright, let's do part b.
Let's do part b.
Explain how the expression
of a limited number
of odorant receptor genes,
you see there's thousands,
receptor genes, can lead
to the perception of
thousands of odors.
Use the evidence about
the number of odorant
receptor genes to support your answer.
So, one way to think
about it is, and this is
this is kind of a theory, here, is that
you don't necessarily have a one-to-one
mapping between odorant, odorant receptors
and odorant molecules, so don't,
don't necessarily,
necessarily have one-to-one
relationship
between, between odorant molecules
odorant molecules and receptor proteins.
And receptor proteins.
Maybe, maybe one protein can,
can detect multiple molecules,
maybe one, maybe a given
protein can
detect multiple molecules.
Or vice versa, or vice versa,
whoops I keep having trouble
with my little pen here.
or vice versa,
or vice, vice versa.
And so then, you could have this
could lead to
many combinations,
combinations being detected.
So even though you could
have, maybe these one
thousand odorant genes,
they code for one thousand
receptor proteins,
and so you might say well,
well those'll only be able
to detect one thousand
different molecules, well, no,
each of those could detect more than one,
and then, and when they come
in different combinations
they might trigger the
brain in different ways.
And then, many, I mean
I could even add that,
this could lead to many
combinations being detected
which would be different,
different smells in the brain,
different smells
as perceived by brain,
perceived by brain.
Now, there is some possibility
that each of these genes,
maybe they could be coded into proteins
in different ways, but they
do tell us each encoding
a unique odorant-receptor, so I like,
I like going with this one,
you don't necessarily have
a one-to-one relationship,
each receptor could
recognize multiple molecules,
or one molecule could be
bound by multiple receptors,
and then the different combinations
of all of the above
means that you could have
much more than one thousand molecules
being detected, and
especially different molecules
in different combinations,
you could have thousands
upon thousands of smells quote, unquote,
being detected.